THE UNITED STATES IS PLEDGING
MORE MILITARY SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE, NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN MADE A
VISIT TO KYIV AND ANNOUNCE
ADDITIONAL $40 MILLION IN
SECURITY ASSISTANCE.
SULLIVAN ALSO REPEATED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLEDGE TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING UKRAINE'S
WAR EFFORT FOR AS LONG AS IT
TAKES, DESPITE SOME BIPARTISAN
CONCERNS ABOUT SUCH AN
OPEN-ENDED AND EXPENSIVE
COMMITMENT.
MEANWHILE, A POSITIVE STEP FOR
UKRAINE'S BATTERED POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN
JAPANESE SHUT IS NOW
RECONNECTED TO THE POWER GRID
AFTER RUSSIAN SHELLING KNOCK IT
OFF LINE.
THAT POWER PLANT IS THE BIGGEST
IN EUROPE.
CRITICAL TO NOT JUST THE
UKRAINE, BUT EUROPE AS WELL, IT
HAS LOST POWER MULTIPLE TIMES
SINCE THE WAR BEGAN.
JOINING US NOW FOR MORE IS CNN
MILITARY ANALYST COLONEL CEDRIC
LEIGHTON.
COLONEL, IF WE LOOK AT THE
UKRAINIAN BATTLEFIELDS.
WHAT WE ARE MOST FOCUSED ON
RIGHT NOW IS THIS AREA DOWN
HERE, KHERSON.
AND THERE IS SOME SPECULATION
THAT THE UKRAINIANS MAY SOON
MOUNTAIN OFFENSIVE THERE.
HOW SIGNIFICANT WOULD THAT BE.
>> ALEX, THEY WOULD USUALLY BE
SIGNIFICANT.
IN FACT, LET'S ZOOM INTO THIS
AREA RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS THE CITY OF KHERSON
RIGHT HERE.
YOU WILL NOTICE, RIGHT ON THE
DEEPER RIVER WHICH FLOWS INTO
THE BLACK SEA, THIS IS A MAJOR
ARTERY.
THINK OF THE MISSISSIPPI RIVER
IN THE U.S..
IT IS BASICALLY DEBATES SAME
KIND OF RIVER.
>> WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT HERE
IS IF THE RUSSIANS WITHDRAW
FROM THE WEST BANK, WHICH IS
ACTUALLY TO THE NORTH OF THE
EAST BANK HERE.
IF THEY WITHDRAW FROM THIS AREA,
THAT MEANS THAT ALL OF THIS
BECOMES UKRAINIAN TERRITORY,
POTENTIALLY.
THE RUSSIANS WOULD AFTER
WITHDRAWING TO THIS AREA, IF
THEY DO THAT THEN WHAT HAPPENS
HERE IS THAT THEY WILL END UP
GOING INTO AN AREA THAT WILL
FORCE DEFENSIVE FIGHTING IN
THIS REGION RIGHT HERE.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS THE
ZAPORIZHZHIA PLANT THAT YOU
JUST TALKED ABOUT.
THE NUCLEAR POWER PLANT.
THE CITY OF ZAPORIZHZHIA IS
STILL IN UKRAINIAN HANDS, THAT
IS UP HERE.
BUT IF THE UKRAINIANS CONTROL
THIS AREA, IF THEY GET TO
CONTROL THIS, THAT IS GONNA BE
A MAJOR VICTORY FOR THE
UKRAINIANS, NO MATTER HOW YOU
SLICE IT.
>> AND IT'S HARD TO TELL THIS
MAP, BY THE CITY OF KHERSON IS
ACTUALLY ON THE WEST SIDE OF
THE RIVER.
THAT IS ARGUABLY BEEN ONE OF
THE BEST SUCCESSES THAT
RUSSIANS HAD IN THE WORSE.
THE ONLY PROVINCIAL CAPITAL
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONQUER SO FAR.
WE SHOULD NOTE, THIS IS JUST
NORTH OF CRIMEA.
FROM CRIMEA THE RUSSIANS HAVE
BEEN LAUNCHING THESE IRANIAN
DRONES.
THEY HAVE INCREDIBLE RANGE.
AND NOW WE HAVE THE IRANIAN
FOREIGN MINISTER ADMITTING THAT
DRONES WERE SENT TO RUSSIA
BEFORE THE WAR STARTED.
WE HAVE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF
UKRAINE SAYING THAT IRAN IS
ACTUALLY DOWNPLAYING THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY HAVE OFFERED
THE RUSSIANS.
AND HE ALSO SAID THAT AROUND
TEN IRANIAN DRONES ARE BEING
SHOT DOWN PER DAY.
WHAT KIND OF EFFECT ARE THESE
DRONES HAVING?
HOW MUCH HELP ARE THEY GIVING
THE RUSSIAN FORCES?
>> THEY ARE GIVING THE RUSSIAN
FORCES AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
HELP, ALEX.
THIS IS VIDEO OF THE SHAHEEN
1:31 JOAN WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON DRONES THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN EMPLOYING.
ALSO HAD A LOT OF TRAINING FROM
THE RIVER.
IF WE GO QUICKLY BACK TO THE
UKRAINE MAP, THEY ARE BASICALLY
HAVING AN EFFECT IN ALL OF
THESE AREAS.
NOT ONLY ON THE FRONTLINES IN
AREAS ESPECIALLY RIGHT ALONG
HERE.
BUT IN CITIES LIKE KYIV AND
EVEN IN SOME CASES THROUGH THE
WEST.
NOT QUITE TO LIVE.
BUT THEY ARE HAVING IN EFFECT
AND ALL OF THESE AREAS, CENTRAL
LOOP RAIN AND OF COURSE THE
SOUTH CENTRAL PART OF THIS
COUNTRY AS WELL.
AND THE OTHER THING IS, OF
COURSE, TO WATCH OUT FOR
OPERATIONS IN THIS AREA.
BECAUSE THAT IS UKRAINE'S MAIN
PORT.
ODESSA.
THAT IS AN AREA, OF COURSE, FOR
ALL OF THE GREEN FLOWS OUT OF
UKRAINE.
AND THAT BECOMES AN IMPORTANT
THING WHETHER OR NOT THAT
CONTINUES.
>> YEAH, THOSE